black people have always been futurists
you see we have to be
afrofuturism claims to reclaim and
transform
the trauma of past atrocities against
the black and afro-queer diaspora
afrofuturism combined science fiction
and fantasy
to re-examine how the future is
currently imagined
to envision alternative futures based on
the black experience
as slavery forced africans to confront
an alien world surrounded by colonial
technologies afrofuturism
is born out of cruelty and that cruelty
of the white imagination
and some complicity with the african
imagination as well
was a necessary condition out of which
the african diaspora had to reimagine
its future
you see the black experience is
futuristic it's more like a middle
passage it's a science fiction horror
story
you know think about this west africa as
our the home planet of the black
diaspora
where with the latest in bondage
technologies
we were transported against our will in
ships
designed to carry rows and rows of
people and chains
and once they got to this alien world in
the americas they were killed if they
spoke their language
or tried to practice their religion or
play their music
in this world they had to innovate adapt
capitulate succumb and rebuild
their former lives and traditions
they were sold auctioned off to the
nearest bidder
families torn apart they had to reinvent
themselves
and create new black technologies
to repair the trauma they had just
experienced and keep
experiencing they were innovators in an
alien landscape
you see they had to create what scholars
call sonic utopias
they're future scenarios spirituals are
future scenarios envisioning zion
it's our vibranium you know the metal
that helped build wakanda this fantastic
metal that you could apply in different
ways
but spirituals were also coded signals
of future liberation
you know that tune swing low sweet
chariot
it's cold for movement something's
getting ready to happen
looked over jordan what did i see it's a
coated metaphor for the ohio river
for slaves that could escape into canada
a band of angels coming after me it's
called for conductors
gonna help me get my freedom so the
spiritual the dance the art
is our cultural vehicle our spaceship
transporting the black imagination to
our future selves and generations
this is our truth our currency our power
and thus we are vibranium